great emphasis on the fact that Lori is
a virgin which turns out to be a word
that they're using connotatively they're
referring to her first time devouring a
victim with the allegory for sex is
obviously still there if my thesis that
Sam is meant to embody Halloween and its
Traditions is correct then I see no
reason that that couldn't include more
recent Traditions like the one where
many young women use their costumes as a
means to draw romantic attention to
themselves in recent decades the holiday
has taken a page from horror movies to
become something both sexy and scary but
when you're a kid hopefully the focus on
Halloween is more about fear and
Mischief so